je sais pas pourquoi je sens qu'on va
aller peut-être danser dans la rue avec
tf1 moment il le sait pas encore
c'est par ya un truc qui se passe à côté
je peux pas tout vous dire mais je me
demande si on va pas les postuler calvet
moi ouais je vous le dis y'a un truc moi
je vais vous dire ce que c'est pas tant
je vous décris toi il ya la conférence
de presse de danse avec les stars
l'aaa à 100 m et 200 m je me suis dit si
on ya les caves et moi aller danser en
plus ça leur fera une personne connue
pour le casting devrait postuler pour la
nouvelle saison donc je ne sais pas il
paraît qu'un tapis rouge et où il ça
vous pouvez venir +2 connaissez le
chemin je peux te faire entrer si chez
moi bah oui c'est apaisant tf1 oui oui
le cher voisin exactement sa rentrée je
vais y aller après cette vanne moi j'ai
passé pouvait nous faire entrer ouais
merci très bien là il est peu plus nous
fait rentrer à tf1 combien de nuits ses
sensations avec valence à qui ça à te
dire mon sport mais vous nous direz
danse avec là c'est clair sinon
justement j'ai un truc est bien géré la
conférence de presse de danse avec les
stars n'en voulait pas qu'il y ait m'ont
proposé d'y participer à danse avec les
stars d'état du travail tu peux pas j'ai
déjà réduit ses mauvais là j'ai dit je
suis passé ternas parena l'homme serait
pas sa tenue le gagner on va prouver y
aller à lima pour de vrai bon bien sûr
oui elle est folle on fout la merde non
les états unis
jacobs mais quand j'ai vu la merde c'est
gentiment ben oui j'en veux un temps
certain goût dans le bus on va aller
chez tf1 on y va maintenant on va y
aller on battre twente est prêt mais le
truc on va partir chez tf1 on va essayer
postuler pour danse avec les stars qui
veulent venir
on y va moi je suis choqué on les joue
plus oui nous on ne va pas tarder car
audrey bien aussi on va aller chez tf1
on y va maintenant on va y aller on
battre twente mais le premier truc on va
partir chez tf1 on va essayer postuler
pour danse avec les stars qui veulent
venir
on y va moi je suis choqué on les joue
plus oui nous sommes américains ont très
bien aussi les petites beauté on est de
retour sur d8 on est en direct on est à
quelques mètres de tf1 avec kev adams
alain gautré la mine avec des danseuses
orientales à baky sadoul black est
derrière regarder la touche 10,1
doubiens bas mais ça on va essayer de de
postuler pour d'un sacré ce congrès
j'arrive
alors on y va on va à tf1 c'est parti on
va leur dire qu'on aime cette émission
qu'on a envie de participer
nous aussi on aime les on aime la danse
il est ok vrac est hélas elle est outrée
j'y suis allé derrière andré therrien
allez on y va
j'espère qu'ils vont pas fermer des
portes j'espère qu'on va pouvoir y aller
non attends l inquiète pas j'ai les clés
je connais leur tête cheikh
qu'est ce qui se passe on est à
l'antenne wen a lancé le match tu me
fais tout moi elle avait envie de vous
quand même de montrer sa poitrine vas-y
très bon ben voilà ça c'est fait allez
on arrive on est à quelques mètres de
tf1 on espère que l'accueil va être
chaleureux parce qu'on les aime bien
vraiment on les aime bien des fois oui
c'est vrai contrarié moi je travaille
c'est une recette c'est pas si près
comme le tf
cernay qui me voit habillée comme ça il
dit ceci rayonnement ça fait vraiment
plaisir
ch'est tu sais que vraiment le nouveau
moyen de blast âge ça fait vraiment à
bavois laoula ya des barrières scénarise
regarder tf1 c'est là notre chaîne près
d'y aller ya pas si rouges ses astuces
et la même conférence de presse de danse
avec les stars et on veut en net de
cette émission on aime danse avec les
stars et on va se faire recaler comment
ça va on adore cette émission ça valait
chéri on aime cette émission on aime
danse avec les stars
comment ça va mais chérie ça va bien ça
va merci la taille on voulait dire voilà
où on sait que c'est la conférence de
presse de danse avec les stars
on aime cette émission absolument c'est
gentil on voulait postuler en fait qu'à
madame ce mois yahoo trélat millions
c'est qui veut faire dans chaque pays la
finale et ont très bien bay à la fois il
ya issa doumbia on veut on peut en est
de cette émission parce qu'on aime la
danse
donc ces danses ou voilà on peut vous
faire des vitres et venir nous faire des
petits vision d'un mais c'est vrai ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut leur dire
bonjour papa vous comprenez que c'est
pas possible vraiment parce qu'on vous
faire des dons je sais c'est gentil
sympa moi j'ai toujours rêvé de voir la
conférence de presse de danse avec les
stars et on adore un instant nous non
plus on adore les missions non mais je
la regarde tout le temps allez-y
annoncées conjuguées des sorties de
zoric ryan bensetti s'est vite fait
pourquoi nous sommes très sympa mais
vraiment j'aime bien monsieur mais il
est gentil mais c'est rien alors eh bah
tant pis alors nous ce que c'est ça on
va faire des danses ici dans ce vent
ces roms avaient longtemps
on n'a pas parce qu'on n'a pas un truc
poste pour la poste on l'oublié poste
cette valve c'est en direct du conte à
un poste à poste à poste aura pas de
bases non j'ai pas de poste merci hugo
merci à hugo lui demanda posthume datcha
pour vous demande et renvoie là mais on
adore hugo c'est pour ça qu'on les
remercie
sans regret on peut pas vous faire alors
on peut pas faire une petite danse avec
moi il ya isabelle morini-bosc ont très
vite fait mais tu vas t'enfoncer
continent on peut passer pas voilà c'est
celle qui ferait directeur de la com il
est super sympa je l'adorais sur le deal
est super sympa regardez on va rentrer
et on va rentrer et son économie
je les adore non mais vraiment plus
défaut ils sont très sympas avec nous
mêmes avec papa sortir la rigolade
merci frédéric et a tué deux ans non
mais parce qu on aime d'enceinte et
triste a commenté le shérif mecheri
dents mais je vous explique une grande
actrice d'une fiction peut-être oui mais
on est on aime tous c'est au tour de
téléphone et on dirait qu'on à l'entrée
d'une boîte c'est que la famille
juste après ce soir mais sinon la
conférence de presse n'ont par contre ce
que je peux vous proposer c'est de faire
un petit selphy devant le hashtag danse
avec les stars comme ça au moins de
frais de publicité pour l'édition vous
et tous vos téléspectateurs à venir voir
l'émission à la fin du mois d'octobre à
9 ans on adore danse avec les stars
regardez mais justement pour qu'on lui
aurait offert on se presse c'est avec
des gens qui ont le sens rue c'est pas
envie d'être filmés et il faut respecter
ça par contre ce que je peux vous
proposer
c'est cyril kev est bien utilisé dans
toi et sur toi vous venez vous fait un
petit 1 qui photos de vandales c'est
qu'après vous pousser ça on voit
l'ambiance
allons voyons mais moi je trouve tous
les perdants dans la négo on le sait
rien on est perdant dans la négo aura
pas droit devant la séance de presse et
on leur fait la pub pour l'émission j'ai
rien contre l émission apprend à
négocier et cyril à la série n'a pas
tort françois la pâte au jeu mais dire
qu'on rêverait de venir de danse avec
les stars
si on rêve de la prochaine fête et
brochets inscris toi pour l'année
prochaine
inscrivez vous pour l'année prochaine
aujourd'hui mais dont l'un au mieux on
est plat soyez sympa on est plein
attends je me laissais commune de bouaye
screen bois ils te disent tu peux pas
rentrer mais chez nous il a pu pour la
boyne frérot sac lesté les bonis venez
venez venez venez ya une ambiance
festive allez on y va en chauny on
évoque ce jeudi c'est parti allez voila
voila c'est à au moins on est rentré
voilà c'est ou alors voyez condé rentrée
si vous le faites avec nous si on fait
comme si vous êtes dans ce mode est là
on fait comme si on va le faire ça va
aller on se met tous là voilà mais
l'annoncé 15h ça débarque au stade et
marc fin octobre faisait regarder mais
surveillez le 24 24 24 octobre
bah voilà danse avec les stars merci mes
demoiselles venues voilà mais moi ça
devenait aller moi ce que je propose les
chéris c'est qu'on fasse celle fillon va
tout seul devant danse avec les stars le
24 octobre ce qu'on aime cette émission
on adore cette émission mais on est
perdant quand même dans les négociations
et gagne encore tf1 alors défense est
déjà le premier générique on peut faire
juste un truc avant de partir est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire juste une petite
chenille dans le hall de tf1 s'est fait
à deux ans et terminant si on leur fait
aussi à les séparer
l'équipe
bajolet vallat
m
que vous
on vient
casting avait prochaine ça ne le shérif
salut et merci
salut des pâquis madjid et 8 n'ya pas de
mal
la du carrelage pas là tu me fais peur
allez mon bertrand finet la chronique on
arrête tu d'un plateau no mercy que ça
lui est cher